[Music]
talk to me about being here and why it's
so important it's important because I
think it's good for kids to see people
who I looked up to in social media tell
them that it's okay to be kind to each
other and it's okay to be a good person
and help other people and so I'm excited
for the kids to be inspired today you
said something about kids looking up to
people on social media and who inspires
you to be a better person who are you
Alicia Keys is here today and I'm
fangirling inside kids she's me and my
sisters absolute favorite and so I look
up to her I also look up to Tori Kelly's
having a good role model makes it easier
for you to be a better person so what is
it about Alicia key I think it's just
her charisma and her personality she's a
very chill and passionate about what she
does and I love that about her have you
ever met her or today will be the first
time no today will be the first time if
I don't you know fall to the ground
beforehand but not about what you're
gonna say right I've been watching
Dancing with the Stars this season I
have I think it's amazing I had her got
voted off which is interesting she's
absolutely incredible but at the same
time you know it's just everybody's got
to work as hard as they possibly can
because you know it's all about that and
it's also about the votes so many people
were so surprised by that what do you
think happened
I'm not really sure honestly I mean it
usually goes by boat yeah but at the
same time I mean I wish everybody could
stay on there's such amazing dancers and
everybody works so hard so have you
talked to Simone at all yeah I mean I I
told her where it's talks with her heels
so that way she doesn't get blisters on
her feet and yeah um
my partner showed me that one and so
yeah I saw that you are possibly
thinking about returning to the 2020
Olympics in Tokyo is that is that going
to happen are you training right now I'm
not training right now I'm actually
taking a little break just because this
past year has been a little bit of a
whirlwind but I will be coming back in a
few months
[Music]
you